you know I spent six years researching
and writing this book on nuclear weapons
and now I've spent almost a year talking
about the book going to international
meetings meeting with government
officials about these issues and it has
not left me feeling apocalyptic I don't
feel doomed I don't feel depressed I'm
not medicated but here's what it's left
me feeling deeply concerned I don't
think there's anything inevitable about
a nuclear disaster about a nuclear
catastrophe but it's absolutely urgent
that we be aware of these risks and then
we take you know basic steps to reduce
the danger and that's one of the reasons
that I wrote the book that's one of the
reasons I'm still speaking about it a
year later and if I felt that we were
doomed and I felt that there was nothing
that could be done about this problem
there are a lot more entertaining things
that I could be doing with my time so
there are very simple things that we
need to push for that will greatly
reduce the risk as long as these nuclear
weapons exist in the world fully
assembled they're going to present the
danger of mass murder it's just that
simple but what we can do is reduce the
number of nuclear weapons in the world
that's hugely important we can prevent
other countries from getting nuclear
weapons on the last step is we need to
lock up all the bomb grade uranium and
plutonium in the world to prevent
terrorists from getting hold of it
stealing it and making nuclear weapons
President Obama has spoken to a vision
of a world without nuclear weapons
abolishing nuclear weapons and i support
that as well it was the policy of Ronald
Reagan President Kennedy all the way
back to President Truman so someday I
hope that'll happen but before that day
comes we really really need a public
debate and discussion on these issues
and we need to do everything we can and
taking concrete steps to reduce this
danger there's a there's a natural kind
of instinct to just get into bed pull
the sheets over the head
and not deal with this or dig a bunker
and you know install high-speed internet
& and protect yourself from it but
there's all kinds of ways that ordinary
people can get engaged in this issue get
active on this issue and may change the
two greatest dangers that we face in
this country existential dangers are
climate change and nuclear weapons and
the thing about climate change is you
know maybe it can be reversed maybe the
harms can be you know reduced but the
detonation of a nuclear weapon is going
to be instantaneous and it's going to be
irreversible and so that's something
that I think we we really need to be
focusing on as well as climate change